OUT THERE FOR THE RANGERS
AGAINST SIDNEY CROSBY.
THAT'S CONTROLLED BY AHEAD.
HERE'S DRYDEN HUNT IN FRONT.
GREAT   QUICK.
RYAN STROME GETS AN EXCELLENT
CHANCE TO TRISTAN JARRY.
AN OUTSTANDING SAVE ON HIHI POW.
PITTSBURGH, THE THIRDRD CREEPIN
THE DEADLINE.
LOST IT.
CARTER HEADS TO THE NET AND
TRIES TO TIP IT IN, OFF
RYAN LINDGREN, COULDN'T CONNECT
CARTER.
KREIDER ENDS UP WRAPPING UP KRE.
ZAC JONES, WAITED FOR STROME TO
CLEAR.
RANGERS IN T A
SKATE ANDPERIOD.
CENTERING PASS FOR BOYLE. TERRI
CHANCE.
NOT AFRAID TO GET INVOLVED IN
THTH OF THIS.
GEUNTZEL'S TURNED
CENTERING FEED BOUNCED TO
LAFR
LAFRENIERE.
KREI STRONGER
MAN.
AND BOYLE JUST BY ZIBANEJAD.
FOR JARRY.
ZIBANEJAD AGAIN, DEFLECTED WIDE
BY DUMOULIN. FOR TROUBA.
A LOT OF SKILLS.
BAD PASS BY THE TOP OF
THE BLUE CREASE.
HE HITS HIM IN THE CHEST BECAUSE
THERE'S NOWHERE TO GO.
HE WANTS T
RUST, 17 GOALS IN HIS LAST 20
GAMES.
CROSBY BACK OUT THERE.
OFF THE STICK OF RUST.
AND SWEPT AWAY BY SHESTERKIN.
CROSBY, TOUGH ANGLE.
BLOCKED FRIEDMAN.
EVGENI MALKIN FOR HEINEN.
WHATOPPED IN THE NEUTRAL ZONE B
TROUBA.
SENT IN BY CROSBY.
AND THE PENGUINS CHAN
OUR RULES
GUENTZEL AT THE TOP OF THE
CREASE.
IT'S LETANG, W
>> Sean: NEW YORK POWER PLAY
PLAY GOALS. TROUBA.E
ATTACKED IN THE CORNER BY  BY S.
NOW, DROPBACK FOR HUNT. WITH TH
FOURTH LINE HERE WITH JUST
OVER -- UNDER THREE MINUTES
LEFT.
THEY ARE GETTING READY
ZIBANEJAD, SENDS IT IN WIDE.
PANARIN TRYING TO GET THERE
FIRST.
LAFR
LAFRENIERE.